yes only ET is with Morgan Wallen in his
hometown to celebrate his brand new
album
[Music]
I spent a lot of time on this field
still looks the same pretty much I think
they got a new scoreboard
um
yeah I mean I feel like this this place
right here played a huge part in making
me who I am yeah how often have you been
able to come back or is this like really
the first big return yeah this is a
this is this is not the first time but
it's the first time in a long time
so
yeah I'm just I'm pretty emotional about
it honestly oh Morgan you have tears in
your eyes
I mean it's important to me you know and
it's just I never
I never thought that I would be able to
do this you know so
um I had I had dreams of playing
baseball you know and my life obviously
took a different turn for the better God
had different plans but it's just a lot
of good things that run through my head
when I step on this field so
this makes me probably more proud than
almost anything you know there's a lot
of different emotions for me you know
coming back and graduating here in 2011
um I love this place it came back here
today and and just uh felt you know so
many different feelings that I didn't
know I was going to feel
shocked the seniors at his alma mater
with an invite to a special performance
presented by Spotify on his former
baseball field his two and a half year
old Indy was there too enjoying the rain
your sweet son is playing in the puddles
right now he's already did it once today
it is loving this so
understand what Dad does like does he
will he understand tonight when you're
on this I think he's just now getting to
that age when I walked off stage in that
Auditorium with those students and
they're all cheering for me and
everything you know I saw him he was
like he was looking at me like
why why why are they doing that you know
why they like you so much there's a lot
of special people here for me tonight I
got my family I got my little boy how
would you say Indy has changed your
perspective your outlook on life and
made you a better man every day was just
I didn't have like a whole big plan you
know I kind of just floated floated till
I got to that point it's what it felt
like anyway
um but when he when he was born it kind
of just it put a whole new purpose and
perspective in my mind and I know how
important my dad was to me so
um I'm just trying to trying to be that
for him one thing at a time out Now
features 36 yes 36 d deeply personal
songs touching on everything from
fatherhood to Morgan's relationship with
women and alcohol
[Music]
album number three is finally here how
does it feel it feels different you know
just because I'm different I'm in a
different place in my life than I was in
the last one so
um I'm really proud of it your last
album of course made history it smashed
streaming records why did you want to
team up with Spotify to celebrate album
number three yeah well they this is
actually their idea they came to to us
we immediately jumped on it
um they've always been good to us and
we're a good partner and
um yeah I was just a thrilled my biggest
takeaway listening to the album from
start to finish was your personal growth
it's very evident throughout this body
of work but you're also the first person
to admit that you're still a work in
progress as we all are how therapeutic
how healing how helpful was putting this
album together for you it was
um tremendously I think
I've always just music has always spoke
to me in a in a different way than
anything else you know I do care about
what people think of me out you know I
want to be viewed as a as a good man I
just want that to to be known I'm just
doing the best I can in this album you
dive into a lot of heartbreak
I'm not gonna ask you who broke your
heart but how was your heart now my
heart feels good now
[Music]